I guess passive resistance or nonviolent
resistance
no no not non resistance it's actually
it's a one step further than
non-violence it's like you don't even
resist that's what that's what Tolstoy
was talking about it's it's from the
sermon of the mount where he had where
Christ said resist not evil I was like
you don't even resist it and so I
thought that there was a metaphysics to
that potential yeah well then I would
say that you you you've asked me a
question that I can't answer I mean I
guess that would be in the same line as
turn the other cheek now that's that's
in a way it's actually yeah yeah there's
some nuance there I thought there is
there is because turn the other cheek
means don't participate in an escalating
cycle of violence and that's reasonable
man if you can do that resist not evil
you know when I go into the Sermon on
the Mount I go into all the individual
lines and look up multiple translations
and multiple interpretations and try to
because and sometimes that's extremely
interesting like for example yeah when I
just there's a line in the New Testament
that's the meek shall inherit the earth
that's not the right translation oh
really
that is not what that means that means
and it's germane to our discussion that
means those who have called those who
are competent to use force but do not
wield it will inherit the earth that is
a whole different issue I would like to
see exactly what resist not means huh
because my suspicions are that the
Devils in the details but it's
definitely a sufficiently jarring
in injunction to be worthy further
investigation especially because I've
heard you talk in the past about how how
futile it is to show up somewhere with a
placard that's probably a very expressed
version of of how resisting what you
deemed to be evil just the act of
resisting it alone is so useless uh-huh
it's a waste of energy right like actual
and that's a very interesting take on
that so that's why I've been thinking
about continuing my whatever you might
describe it as struggle let's say with
thee the forces that are corrupting the
university you know I thought for a long
time in terms of war metaphors with
regards to that and then over the summer
when I got a bit of a break and was able
to think more clearly or begin to think
more clearly about whatever it is I
might be doing I realized that my
primary role on YouTube and perhaps
publicly is not the leader of a war
against the social justice warriors it's
more like Konica encouragement and
education yes with that as a side effect
let's say maybe concern but if it's a
war then it's the wrong approach your
spike yes maybe you also dignify your
enemy with the war you actually encode
their power right resistance as a waste
of time that's really useful risk you
yeah waste of energy you bet you bet
well it has all those aspects we
discussed it has the glorification of
the enemy as well because it might be
far more effective to say that whole
thing is dead here's a different way
you